[Music]
[Applause]
rock has died he was 30 years old
e.t has confirmed the philadelphia
rapper whose real name is rakeem allen
was killed in a robbery and shooting at
roscoe's chicken and waffles in los
angeles on monday his girlfriend posted
a picture on one of her social media
accounts of their meal along with the
geo-tagged location according to the l.a
police department a suspect brandished a
firearm inside the restaurant and they
might have demanded items from allen
believed to be jewelry the suspect shot
allen and ran out the side door to a
getaway car
allen was then transported to a hospital
and was pronounced dead just before 2pm
pacific time nicki minaj who
collaborated with pnb rock on his song
fendi paid tribute on twitter
[Music]
in her tweet she also addressed gun
violence in the hip-hop community quote
the people around these rappers gain so
much it's time to start really reminding
them over and over at least try to put
your foot down if you care tell them
you're not loved like you think you are
your prey in a world full of predators
what's not clicking he was such a
pleasure to work with condolences to his
mom and family this makes me feel so
sick jesus i want to hear it again
you love me
[Music]
pnb rock released his single love me
again on september 2nd his label
atlantic records told et in a statement
quote pnb rock was more than an artist
to many rakeem allen was a great friend
he was also a wonderful father to two
beautiful little girls this news is
heavy on our hearts and we are all
hurting over this senseless loss our
thoughts and prayers are with his family
during this difficult time
[Music]